you you can believe whatever you like
but the problem with this issue and why
it's become such a contentious issue is
because it's gone far beyond people just
living their lives and doing what they
want to do it's got into an ideological
movement where they are now trying to
force people to believe and comply with
it oftentimes at the threat of
punishment someone said that why are
they not answering that question someone
said because they'll get fired right
that's coercion right if you are not
allowed to say something that is
factually correct and true because
you're worried about losing your job
you're not in a good place in society